all right here coming in hot we're just
grilling and smoking and doing what we
like to do I like to smoke to JA
supposed to have some of those top-notch
grills around yes we do yeah tell me
about the Gator pit Gator pit is a
custom hit shop custom pitch custom pits
just like a custom car shop except we
trick out pits light light not not like
in NASCAR this kind of way you don't
think yeah exactly
smokers grills and what you do to them
we take them from raw steel yeah we
actually turn it into this finished
product raw steel Rostov another night
ugly angle roughly so so so each one is
a one of one and this this is the only
one you'll ever see like this yeah so
when you out to again you got to worry
about somebody having the same grill
than the same mate nobody's you how long
does it take the meat this one was too
much four to five welders on it one time
we've got two thousand eight hundred and
eighty eight feet the welds on that's a
lot of milk everything is custom made by
hand from the stainless to the pipe to
the plate you see right here we've
custom painted everything paint job on
this was a right six trams really what
made you start doing this customization
stunt when I was in high school I
started welding an FFA and I was doing
barbecue pits for the high school a
little side hustle right I was it over
there and then it just went from there
and I just turned it into a hobby and
into my job what I do it's what I've
been doing and talking about it all of
it all you got to do is find something
that you good and find something that
you like doing find a passion and you
can capitalize off of so what Gator pit
name come from I'm from Louisiana
south Louisiana grew up with them
Louisiana cash one of them ate them
behind a NATO EEE
kiss no gate and eat one oh yeah you did
oh yeah you called him Lisa got there
that we just got there and catch them
just for fun and play with them yeah oh
yeah and then would eat them I'm scared
a it's angle I'm scared eggs how much
this cost you this right here this one
you're gonna be minimum 30 grand for a
BBQ smoker and black folds on by this 30
green thirty thousand start how many
days you settling you doing good I got a
one-year waiting list you order anything
from it's gonna take you minimum one
year to get it from me so you're doing
really good - an excellent really good
so wait you stationed it I'm in Houston
you in Houston we ship them all over the
world and you got some satisfied
customers overseas I got them in
Australia Russia Finland Hong Kong
Thailand I got three going to Korea this
month you've been on my show yet I don't
want to get you popular but you don't
need me what else we got but no you
smoke with it but you man you gotta know
how to greet or - nothing you can't just
be making these you know I'd agree we
teach cooking classes that's an
excellent idea
yeah I got a website Gator pit barbecue
school calm then you teach you how to
grill and they come it's a one day class
so how much for the class how much would
that cost it's 500 ahead father ahead
for one day well as 2330 students today
miss lifetimes twenty and thirty
students a day yeah so look I think
that's a great idea so not only do you
get a thirty thousand dollar grid you
can Co get classifier hunting we're
gonna teach you how to unionize you put
gas in the truck and everything you'd be
down oh yeah almost oh yeah oof
it's expensive man and they get out they
get a big thick book over 60 pages color
pictures in there come on come to class
give me give me give me a free free
trial - clintus five hundred a head
ain't goody
come on we got you a gift box yeah just
ask for just act yeah I appreciate this
I appreciate any choice I appreciate the
good energy man what the hell is your
jacket at me